I was always big my story was that I was
fat and I was sort of doomed to be fat
and unhappy and not live the life that I
wanted to live so being able to break
down that story it's been a lifelong
process for me and that's what I really
am aiming to share with other people is
that that story doesn't have to be true
[Music]
i'm dana fall study and i am a yoga
teacher Yoga is for everyone why do
people need to be skinny to do yoga this
is it's just it doesn't even make sense
to me it's the only thing that you need
to practice yoga is the willingness to
try welcome so even bigger breath on
this inhale so belly rises up towards
the sky Rock the hips from side to side
just anything that feels good I travel
all over the world teaching
body-positive workshops so I don't
necessarily teach in a way that is about
modifying or making the practice easier
for anybody based on age or size or
anything like that it's more about
teaching in a way that makes everyone
feel really included and really
comfortable and lift the left arm up I
don't care what it looks like I don't
care what any of you look like just do
it and just feel amazing
[Music]
from like age 10 or so on I was always
big three years ago started going to the
gym and just being really active in the
pursuit to get smaller and I lost almost
a hundred pounds I got to my new body
and everything was exactly the same
I wasn't happier and I didn't feel any
better and so I was at this point where
I felt really just kind of lost and
confused about what I needed and so I
went to yoga
before I practiced I didn't realize how
capable my body was because I just felt
like it was fat and like I was lazy and
I believed everything about my body that
sort of society sees when they see a fat
person
I love my body which is crazy because I
really spent my whole life hating it I
mean looking in the mirror and just
feeling so disgusting and I'm proud of
it now and I'm proud to take care of it
you